we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two david p
here's a voicemail that came in let's
take a listen to this
hey david just an idea for a new segment
you know maybe for the bonus show best
you go to the comments section and
comment on the highest rated comment
anybody yeah it'd be beautiful okay
that's an interesting idea
i kind of like that i go through the
previous day's youtube videos and we
look at the highest-rated comment on
each topic and then i react or respond
to that could be an interesting way to
do more audience involvement i'm not
against it yeah i like it i'll have to
run it by the production team yes oh
yeah yeah i have to run it by our puppet
masters and make sure that it's okay
because i'm just a puppet in this entire
thing on the bonus show today saudi
arabia at last will allow women to drive
will this devolve the country into chaos
or will it be no big deal because as we
know women drive in most of the
countries on earth sponges turning
cities into natural sponges to try to
counteract the impact of climate change
of global warming china's doing this and
we're going to talk about it on the
bonus show and also google has unveiled
a smart denim jacket it's a jacket that
can read your text messages to you kind
of weird right will pat wear the jacket
we will discuss that and more on today's
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up patreon.com slash
david pakman show can also give you
access to the bonus show at the $5 a
month level and you can of course
support the work we do
if you shop on amazon by going to david
pakman.com slash amazon before you shop